il y a trois mille ans les premiers
peuples apparaissent sur le continent
européen sans que pour autant la vie
humaine est une grande valeur les hommes
s'entretuent pour la conquête des
territoires et ceux qui ne meurent pas
dans les batailles sont réduisent en
esclavage par les vainqueurs
les millénaires secours
le continent européen connaît la culture
grecque
la domination romaine et l'occupation
germanique maison l'an mil de notre ère
la vie ne vaut toujours pas grand chose
acclamé comme des héros x les rouages
guerriers sont de véritables bushiste
poursuivant la chasse à l'esclave au
delà des mers et voulant convertir à
leur dieu ceux qui ne le connaissent pas
ce dieu est un concept diffusé en europe
par des prêtres provenant du proche
orient des hommes visionnaires prêche
une dimension divine
au delà du monde réel il affirme qu'il
existe un dieu l'unique créateur du ciel
de la terre et de l'homme et que ce dieu
a envoyé son fils jésus sur terre pour
pardonner les péchés des êtres humains
toutefois des conceptions différentes et
des dissensions apparaissent au sujet de
ce même dieu et provoquent de sanglant
conflit n'est content
continue jusqu'au début du 20e siècle
avec les guerres mondiales qui dévaste
le continent européen
les causes des millions de morts
finalement un beau jour de l'an 1945
après avoir versé tant de sang et de
larmes
les maîtres du monde arrête les
hostilités ils signent la paix
les biens sont alors échangé plutôt que
voler le commerce prospère et la vie
devient un délicat équilibre à gérer non
plus par les armes mais par la
négociation
les deux puissances gagnante de la
dernière guerre mondiale émerge alors
les états unis et l'union soviétique les
états unis prônent le capitalisme et
vise un contrôle global du monde
soumises à leur ordre les guerres
mondiales ne s'étant pas déroulé sur
leur continent
ils peuvent ainsi produire et vendre une
énorme quantité d'armes sans être
dérangé devenant si riche qu'il
parvienne à imposer le dollar américain
comme monnaie internationale au lieu de
l'or
l'union soviétique prône le communisme
et la dictature son territoire est le
plus vaste de la planète et à la fin des
guerres mondiales
il englobe les pays de l'est l'europe
elle est au coeur des intérêts des états
unis et de l'union soviétique se
retrouvant en face à face sur ce
continent accablé par les guerres
mondiales
il n'est pas bien difficile pour ces
deux puissances de se le partager
formant ainsi deux blocs le bloc bleu un
l'idéologie capitaliste comprenant les
pays de l'europe occidentale sous
l'influencé des états unis et le bloc
rouge à l'idéologie communiste
comprenant les pays de l'europe
orientale sous l' influence de l'union
soviétique c'est la guerre froide entre
les deux blocs
aux antipodes quant au mode de pensée
dans le bloc rouge
tout est propriété d'état la liberté de
voyager est restreinte
le commerce est contrôlé et la
concurrence interdite
quand le bloc bleu
au contraire la propriété et privé la
liberté de mouvement est totale et le
commerce et la concurrence sont libres
au fil des années
l'énorme richesse des états unis
favorisent des citoyens du bloc bleu qui
étalent leur satisfaction
cela entraîne l'envi silencieuse des
citoyens du bloc rouge leur régime
n'admettant pas la contradiction
pourtant un pays rouges la pologne aux
un jour se rebeller réclamant les
aspirations légitimes de tout homme elle
prétend sortir du système communiste
pour embrasser le capitalisme qui s'ils
n'offrent pas toujours les ans offre
semble t-il au moins la liberté
pensant qu aucun état n'oserait
intervenir dans leurs affaires privées
parce qu'il serait bien trop dangereux
pour quiconque de s'immiscer dans les
questions du bloc rouge craint par le
monde entier
les chefs de l'union soviétique décide
alors d'occuper militairement ce pays
rebelles mais cette menace d'invasion
d'un pays qui se proclament leur frère
suscite l'indignation des chefs du bloc
bleu ils se réunissent alors d'urgence
pour concevoir un plan contre cette
agression au plus vite et sans provoquer
la guerre ils doivent s'arracher la
pologne au bloc communiste de telle
sorte que les chefs rouges sous le
regard du monde entier n'interviennent
pas réussir affaiblirait
considérablement l'adversaire
à la recherche d'un plan diaboliquement
rusé après maintes cogitations les chefs
du bloc bleu au plus profond de leur
pensée se retrouve inévitablement face à
dieu dieu
les chefs bleus sont des gens
pragmatiques ils doutent de l'existence
de lieux en excluant l'intervention
divine sur laquelle on ne peut pas
compter il pense alors au peuple de dieu
à l'église à ses fidèles et l'un d'entre
eux à l'idée sa sainteté
il est alors reconnu que les européens
fusse-t-il du bloc bleu ou du bloc rouge
son fidèle au même dieu et suivent le
sort de l'église
que se passerait-il si sa sainteté le
représentant de dieu sur terre était un
prêtre natif de la pologne
ce pays sur le point d'être agressé et
que se passerait-il si cette même
sainteté en tant qu'homme se sentait
obligé de défendre sa terre qui oserait
la frappe est parmi les soldats rouges
qui sont des gens du peuple et qu'il
aime comme un père
cela empêcherait probablement l'invasion
quelques jours après cette réunion
sa sainteté moeurs
or pressé par les chefs bleus l'église
désigne alors un grand prêtre polonais
en tant que sa sainteté est cet homme ne
perd pas son temps le jour même de son
sacrement
il envoie un message à toutes les
nations du monde il déclare que si son
pays est attaqué il se postera à la
frontière et qu'avec dieu
à ses côtés une mode ira pour l'éternité
quiconque oserait frappé sur le chef de
l'église
le message serait en vie tu es fait
grand bruit
immédiatement les nations et les églises
du monde entier font savoir que sa
sainteté est à protéger en tant que
représentant d'un dieu et ce même s'il
n'est pas le leur
au même moment les états unis et le bloc
bleu déclare que si le chef de l'église
est en danger ils interviendront
militairement
l'impact sur la population du bloc rouge
est considérable l'idée que sa sainteté
soient tués par eux-mêmes agite les
esprits
l'anathème proférées par ce symptôme
rappelle que si la vie est courte
l'âme elle est éternelle et nul ne
voudrait salir la sienne à jamais en
frappant sur le chef de l'église pour
les chefs rouges
la situation est délicate s'ils veulent
éviter un conflit avec le reste du monde
il ne leur reste qu'une solution ce
grand prêtre doit mourir si sa sainteté
précédente est décédé à l'improviste et
certainement avait-elle été assassiné
l'actuel peut aussi bien mourir
subitement que le monde pense à une
malédiction contre l'église ou à une
intrigue su ce meurtre ne laisse pas de
traces nul n'aura rien à redire
cette invasion doit se faire coûte que
coûte et avec fermeté
l'histoire enseigne qu'il est plus sûr
d'être craint que d'être aimé
empoisonné sa sainteté n'est pas chose
possible
le siège de l'église située dans le bloc
bleu est impénétrable
toutefois il est coutume que sa sainteté
sortent en public pendant les fêtes
religieuses
entouré par les très nombreux fidèles
qui l'acclament à grands cris de joie
voilà ce sera quand sa sainteté sortira
de son palais profitant de la confusion
qu'il faudra la tuer
nash et parmi la foule l'assassin peut
s'enfuir
et s'il se fait prendre cela doit
apparaître comme étant le geste isolé
d'un fou qui comme c'est souvent le cas
tu un personnage fameux pour savourer la
notoriété le risque est néanmoins fort
le complot doit rester secret et il faut
se dépêcher pour effectuer cet
assassinat des guerriers rouges qui
n'ont rien à perdre sont choisis ce sont
des hommes durs qui obéissent et ce
texte
condamné à mort pour des crimes ils
seraient graciés et bien récompensés
s'ils réussissaient dans cette
entreprise nécessaire à l'équilibré du
continent ce guerrier parts dont rentrer
furtivement dans le bloc bleu arrive
près de l'église et au moment donné ils
s'infiltrent dans la foule des fidèles
l'un d'eux s'approche de sa sainteté et
au milieu des cris d'épouvanté de ceux
qui sont présents il lui tire froidement
deux balles en plein coeur
mais évidemment dieu existe et il aime
son prêtre bien que perforé de part en
part
sa sainteté survit à cette embuscade et
tandis que le monde crie à l'erreur et ô
miracle
pointant vers l'union soviétique la
pologne exulte le bon sort à empêcher la
mort de son prêtre et la vase où elle
déclare dont l'indépendance aussitôt
aidé par une énorme quantité d'argent
que lui prête le bloc bleu
pasta cette richesse les populations du
bloc rouge reste ébahi
quand le bloc bleu promet à grand pré à
tout pays rousse qui veut le rejoindre
la situation devient incontrôlable
chaque citoyen communiste veut embrasser
le système capitaliste
c'est la fin de l' union solide son pays
chef de file la russie dit sous le bloc
rouge permettant l'indépendance aux pays
et à suzuki et stocke même la production
d'armes laissant entendre au bloc bleu
qu'il doit à présent soutenir ces pays
qu'il a su attirer les chefs le
promettent alors des aides de toutes
sortes
ils sont satisfaits ils n'ont pas
utilisé d'armes et ces pays sont de
nouveaux clients avides d'acheter ce
qu'ils ne trouvent pas chez eux leur
plan a fonctionné
le bloc occidental a désormais la
prédominance sur les armements mais
contre tous utiliser ces arbres alors
que l'ennemi rouge et souriant et
désarmé
l'animosité entre peuples frères qui se
connaissent depuis toujours a disparu
alors comme dans une grande famille où
tous sont unis mais où chacun reste soi
même il se retrousse les manches et la
bonne volonté prévaut en europe
mais un obstacle grave entrave son
économie
plusieurs pays européens jadis puissance
mondiale progresse vite à partir des
ruines des dernières guerres et cela
inquiète les états unis qui suite à la
dissolution du bloc rouge sont devenus
les seuls maîtres de l'europe
leur dessein n'admettant que face aux
assujettis et non pas concurrents les
états unis tram alors pour affaiblir les
pays européens ayant besoin d'une tête
de pont ils s'accordent dans secret avec
l'allemagne lui assurant sa tant désirée
suprématie sur l'europe
puis ils poussent jusqu'à achevées la
fusion des pays européens dans une
structure supranationale l'union
européenne
l'idée est belle mais le piège est tendu
des pays de langue de traditions
différentes
enchaîner entre d'un jour à l'autre
rendent difficiles les décisions
unitaire en particulier lorsqu au sommet
de cette union sont placés des
économistes européens diplômés aux états
unis et à leur solde dont la tâche est
de ralentir l'économie de leur propre
pays enfin quand l'union européenne
mssa devises l'euro basé sur le ressort
de l'allemagne le piège se déclenche
l'euro se montre aussitôt défavorable au
pays à l'économie plus faibles qui ne
peuvent suivre le rythme en allemand
pour rester dans l'union
ces pays ont besoin de beaucoup d'argent
en prévision de cela les états unis crée
un établissement financier privé
la banque dont la branche dans l'europe
a son siège en allemagne la banque
accorde dont un prêt au gouvernement
demandeur mais elle impose des intérêts
exagéré impossible à honorer
c'est une dette qui ne se sont jamais
au fil des décennies les intérêts sur
ces dettes augmentent démesurément alors
que l'europe digère encore senna sont
rouges arriérés qu'elle a avalé en et
mme boucher plusieurs dirigeants de pays
redevable à la banque tels que l'italie
et la grèce se plaignent sur les
intérêts usuriers que leurs
prédécesseurs avaient accepté ils
menacent même de ne plus les honorer la
banque n'attend que ça pour accomplir le
plan américain elle renverse tout
d'abord les gouvernements de l'italie et
de la grèce part d'inédit coup d'état
démocratique les remplaçant par des
exécutifs non-élus soumise à ses ordres
puis elle impose son jeu limitation des
fonds pour la santé publique et pour
l'instruction diffusion d'antivaleurs
des informations la justice elle-même
est entravée deux siècles de luttes
syndicales et de droits acquis sont
violés seuls les manoeuvres spéculatives
au bénéfice de la banque sont exploités
entraînant la vente de biens et de
territoires nationaux et la disparition
des meilleures entreprises n'a peur de
perdre son travail et de ne pas en
trouver un autre devient permanente
la banque ne s'arrête pas et menace
l'espagne le portugal l'irlande et la
france
poursuivant leur abaissement économique
afin qu'ils restent subordonnés aux
états unis
à la recherche désespérée de capitaux
les pays européens décident de se
débarrasser de leurs vieilles âmes qu'en
faire maintenant qu'ils sont en paix
cette ressource devient obsolète tandis
que la demande d'armes reste forte dans
les continents au pays moins avancés
alors ils les leurs ventes
lorsque ces pays reçoivent les âges
l'enfer se déclenche
ils se déchirent entre eux si férocement
d'une grande partie de leur population
fuit désespéré vers l'europe en
affrontant la mort sur des barques de
fortune
les plus chanceux à khost
désorienté détruit par le voyage et par
le chagrin il parle d'une autre land et
souhaite ne pas être chassés ils sont
des centaines de milliers thoune usa
famille et leur peine vient de la vente
de ces maudites âmes
l'union européenne subit ce nouveau
certains se sentant responsable de ces
malheureux qui réclame le droit à la vie
propose de les loger et de les nourrir
comme des frères d'autres disent qu'il
faut les rejetés en mer
puisqu'ils sont d'une autre race et
notre religion
d'autres encore plus modérée disent
avoir besoin de ses bras pour les
travaux que personne ne veut plus faire
les pays européens se partagent pas leur
ces pauvres gens il leur donne un
logement de fortune et le nécessaire
pour la nourriture
8 il les mettre aux travaux les plus
durs
ainsi face à tant de générosité l'europe
revient au beau temps des esclaves
sauf que si jadis été capturé par la
force
maintenant les esclaves arrive de même
c'est inévitable
par un caprice du sort
pour l'ambition de quelques humains
l'histoire de l'europe a été bâti sur
les armes sur l'argent et sur l'
esclavage reste le drame de cet exode
souvent inutiles les rescapés des
guerres qui s'ajoutent aux mendiants du
travail et par la bande
pour sortir de cette confusion
il ne reste plus aux pays de l'union
européenne qu'à faire un seul pas le
plus démocratique pour organiser tous
ensemble un référendum qu'ils demandent
à leurs citoyens s'ils sont d'accord ou
pas avec l'union européenne
avec l'euro imposé sans les consulter
et avec les gouvernements non élus 6 500
millions d'européens pas d'accord que
les pays de l'union reprennent leur
souveraineté comme au bon vieux temps
quand il était riche et puissant et
qu'un mandat d'arrêt international
soient lancées à l'encontre des
seigneurs de la banque qui entre l
europe vers la misère après tout
deviendra beaucoup plus aisée